uh this morning uh approximately 2 30 in
the morning
uh 9-1-1 dispatch received a phone call
from a frantic female stating that her
mother uh was dead
uh then the line was disconnected had no
further details Patrol arrived in the 10
000 block of June flower in the far
south part of town patrol made entry
into the house did find a crime scene a
lot of blood to find a deceased female
the deceased female being described as a
62 year old female she had multiple deep
lacerations a lot of blood
um no sign of any other weapons can't
say anything specific as to a manner of
death but she was pronounced deceased on
scene based on preliminary investigation
we started looking for a daughter
we now have that daughter stopped and in
custody uh in Barstow California with
the help of California Highway Patrol
that occurred about 5 a.m this morning
the daughter being a 28 year old female
right now everything's still very
preliminary still need to go through the
residence they'll need to talk to
neighbors uh uh still need to talk to
the daughter don't have any me forward
for the details as I don't know what
caused an altercation what made it
escalate to this point but at this point
we do have one deceased female and the
suspect is in custody any questions
we believe it was actually the daughter
herself had called before leaving the
scene
uh we do not believe so
uh We've yet to go inside to a search
warrant but we have no information on
any weapons at this time you said you
were called at 2 30 a.m and then you
found the daughter at what time uh 9-1-1
call was made from this Residence at 2
30 this morning
we then started looking for the vehicle
and the daughter CHP was able to locate
stop her take her into custody about 5
a.m this morning in Barstow California
thank you very much